[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour changer un amour notre
amourette il s'en serait pas fallu de
beaucoup mais ce jour là Vénus était
distraite il est des jours où cupide on
s'en fout il est des jours au cupides on
s'en
fout
des jours où il joue les mouches du
coche où elle sent émoussé dans le Bou
les flèches courtoises qu'il nous
décochent il est des jours où Cupid on
s'en fout il est des jours où Cupid on
s'en
[Musique]
fout se consacrant à d'autres
imbéciles il n pas l'heure de s'occuper
de nous avec son arc et tous ses
ustensiles il est des jours où cupide on
s'en fout il est des jours au cupides on
s'en
[Musique]
fout on a tenté sans lui d'ouvrir la
sur l'herbe tendre on s'est roulé mais
vous avez perdu la vertu pas la
tête il est des jours où cupides on s'en
fout il est des jours cupide on s'en
[Musique]
fout si vous m'avez donné toute
lcence le cœur et la n'était pas dans le
cou le feu sacré brillait par son
absence il est des jours ù Cupid on s'en
fout il est des jours ou Cupid on s'en
fout on est feuill à 20 fois la
marguerite
elle tombe à 20 fois sur pas du tout et
notre pauvreil a fait
faillite il est des jours où cupide on
s'en fout il est des jours au Cupid on
s'en
[Musique]
fout quand vous irez au bois cont tes
fleurettes jeune galant le ciel soit
avec vous je n' pas cette chance et le
regrette il est des jours où cupide on
s'en fout il est des jours où Cupid on
s'en
fout